jeremy is whether some tulsa oklahoma hi
Jeremy how are you hi there mr. Ramsey
doing great how about yourself better
than I deserve what's up
yeah wife and I have both recent
graduates we have an Astra mount an
amount of debt looking at two hundred
ninety thousand dollars in student loans
good god here's a doctor a wife has our
doctor physical therapy I have a
master's of embalming Health and Safety
a Bachelors of chemistry and my question
is would it be a bad decision to
purchase a rental property soon yeah
whoa you're broke you're a $300,000 in
debt and you can't get my foot by rental
property no no no no no no you have a
crisis your Congress you have a mess no
no no no you are on beans and rice rice
and beans no vacation you will not see
the light of day you will work like an
animal until you get this mess cleaned
up no you don't buy rental property okay
this is this is our this is what was
done so far we saw a house your program
showed us we couldn't afford it mm-hmm
we sold a house to go $10,000 in debt
here lately
we have $37,000 cash that we have from
selling your house and the rental house
were in right now is $800 a month we
could buy a $60,000 house and have $400
at $400 mortgage and having a dish for
$400 support or debt was my viewpoint on
it
yeah that's assuming the renter pays a
family are paid yet and assuming it's
rented yeah then why is it 2 point
because I wanted what a silver in rental
houses are extremely hard to find there
they stay for seems like ok so I'm a
handyman I I did all the renovations
myself on the last house anything that
come up I would do myself from these
rental houses and we can almost we could
balance a home mortgage and a rental
property mortgage right now cheaper than
we could have a house you have $300,000
and student loan that dude I've never
yet there don't don't talk to me about
buying a rental house don't I mean I'm
gonna go visit Pluto in a minute don't
don't do that
please use the money to get out of debt
keep your life simple quit trying to
borrow your way through all of your
dreams you're turning them into
nightmares pay off the debt
Oh
you